hey guys dr. Berg here in this video we're going
to talk about what causes cracked heels okay now
it's a vitamin b3 deficiency that's what it is
and another name for vitamin b3 deficiency is
called pellagra now there are levels of this
pellagra from very minor subclinical to very
advanced and you know you just don't wake up
one day with pellagra you start with little
tiny symptoms and believe it or not one of the
first symptoms of pellagra it has to do with
your your gastrointestinal tract diarrhea
and a lot of upset inflammation in your gut
and then it leads to the skin so there's a lot
of skin problems with vitamin b3 deficiencies
which is niacin okay so here are the symptoms
of B3 deficiency sensitivity to light cracked
skin rough skin cracked roughed cracked skin
especially on your heels odor sensitivity you
have sensitivity to odors like you could really
smell things and it irritates you more than it
should dizziness with sudden movements so
everything is like hyper sensitive desire
to quarrel fight with someone black tongue now
there's a lot of other symptoms but these are
some of the common ones now the foods that you
should be eating to to make sure you have b3
would be you know some of the animal meats
turkey chicken pork mushroom fish grass-fed
beef seeds avocado now it could be the diet but
normally it's not the diet so what we want to do
is you want to look deeper and the number one
cause of vitamin b3 deficiency in fact all of
the vitamins would be your gastrointestinal tract
is damaged you might have inflammation you might
have a gastric bypass surgery where they took
out your intestines it could be from Crohn's or
celiac or irritable bowel syndrome but something
happened in your gut that destroyed the lining
of your digestive tract and now you can't absorb
that so you're going to have to consume a little
bit more B vitamins than you normally do just so
it can be absorbed so that's something we want
to look at if it is your GI tract then what you
want to do is you want to take al glutamine you
want to take lactic acid from kombucha tea you
want to have more of the fermented foods and
bone broth is a really good source of l-glutamine
as well now if your alcoholic this could also be
the reason why you're deficient in the B vitamins
if you have history a lot of antibiotics that can
destroy the ability to absorb b3 and last one is
too much corn now what's the connection between
corn and b3 there's a research that shows that
certain countries that pretty much are really
really poor in their living off just primarily
corn become very deficient in b3 and they get
pellagra and so I'll put a link down there to
get more data on that but corn does not have
help tryptophan this amino acid l-tryptophan
turns into b3 so if you don't have it that's
why you're going to be deficient so consuming
the diet of you know corn you're going to have
a problem with this deficiency right here so
we just wanted to do a video on the causes of
cracked heels as compared to just putting a lotion
on your feet and bean that's going to fix it this
is more of an internal problem find the cause
go ahead and correct it and thanks for watching